das ist eine absolut spannende
geschichte wie wurde eigentlich die
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung entdeckt
und sie wurde mit ihr ein weiteres indiz
für die urknalltheorie gefunden jetzt in
klick substanzen rutschen
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert der kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
ein video in zusammenarbeit mit der
neugier zone einem niegelnagelneuen
coolen kanal auf youtube
die kosmische hintergrundstrahlung wurde
1964 von den wissenschaftlern arno
penzias und robert wilson eher zufällig
entdeckt als sie versuchten eine horn
antenne für ein radio astronomisches
forschungsprojekt in betrieb zu nehmen
hauptsächlich für
kommunikationssatelliten verschiedene
rausch quellen die der sehr empfindliche
empfänger registrierte mussten beseitigt
werden eine einzige baustelle jedoch
blieb hartnäckig und konnte einfach
nicht beseitigt werden das störsignal
befand sich im mikrowellenbereich und
wie es eine strahlung temperatur von
etwa 3 kelvin auf die strahlung schien
überall im raum und von allen richtungen
absolut gleichmäßig zu sein
durch diese eigenschaft so dachten sich
pence und wilson muss die
emissionsquelle dieser strahlung in
extrem weiter entfernung liegen die
genaue ursache bei den beiden
wissenschaftlern jedoch zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch unklar
nach weiteren messungen und forschung
kamen penzias und wilson zu dem schluss
dass die kosmische hintergrundstrahlung
eine nachwirkung des urknalls ist die
bis heute nachgewiesen werden kann
damals als die urknalltheorie unter den
wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen noch nicht so
anerkannt war wie heute war dies
gleichzeitig ein weiteres argument für
diese theorie denn die urknall theorie
sagt eine solche hintergrundstrahlung
voraus in den ersten rund 380.000 jahren
nach dem urknall war das universum noch
so klein und komprimiert dass es sehr
heiß war frei elementarteilchen und
photonen also lichtteilchen kollidierten
ständig miteinander erst als der raum
durch die expansion groß genug war
konnten sich die photonen von der
materie in koppeln in dieser
rekombination phase wie sie im
fachjargon heißt war die strahlung
dieser photonen mit rund 3.000 kelvin
noch sehr heiß kühlt die jedoch durch
die weitere expansion des universums um
den faktor von rund 1000 weiter ab und
zwar auf den heutigen wert von genau 3
kelvin diese hintergrundstrahlung ist
überall im gesamten universum präsent
und ist sogar für rund ein prozent des
rauschens eines analogen fernsehers der
nach einem nicht vorhandenen programm so
verantwortlich anfangs dachte man diese
strahlung sei absolut konstant und
unterliegt keinerlei schwankungen doch
man fand heraus dass es feinste
unterschiede in der strahlung temperatur
im bereich von mikro grad gibt diese
lassen sich auf dichte unterschiede im
uhr plasma des frühen universums
zurückführen an den orten niedriger
dichte entkoppelte sich das licht früher
von der materie wodurch die strahlung an
diesen stellen etwas kühler ist diese
dichte unterschiede führten dazu dass
sich an den orten hörer die stehen
derzeit nach der rekombination phase die
ersten galaxien bildeten dann für 65
veröffentlichten patches und wilson ihre
forschung und zeigten dass die
urknalltheorie gar nicht so abwegig ist
sie lässt sich perfekt vereinbaren mit
der von edwin hubble im jahr 1929
entdeckten expansion des universums und
immer dann wenn sie in der physik zwei
unabhängige theorien perfekt ergänzen
steckt wohl eine gewisse wahrheit
dahinter und ja die theorie vom urknall
vom big bang gilt inzwischen als
gesichert und noch etwas dabei ist
absolut faszinierend nämlich welche form
hat das universum damals angenommen
genau das ist das thema in diesem video
der neugier zone unbedingt anschauen
also draufklicken welche form hat das
universum mega spannend und ein absolut
cooler ganz neuer kanal
da besteht absolut tabu sagen können sie
auch jetzt schon direkt wir machen
einfach draufklicken und ihr kommt zum
kanal bis dann würde ich mal sagen
bleibt dran